it's always Sam Raimi's Evil to its
audience
but it is so campy and fun and yeah
you'd never heard of it like you'd never
a blockbuster you couldn't really find
it but I know of it I don't know it's
what that's that exists for me and one
of those movies that there's one of
those like that genre of movies I've
always known about and I know and I
haven't watched anything Bruce Campbell
ever and there's a chance I may be loved
it and I don't know if the train has
left the station and I'll never know
okay just you know like at Blade Runner
I've never watched blade I know and
people people are like you've got to see
Blade Runner I'm like but what if time
is gone now I know but I think they're
evergreen movies I agree with that first
yeah yeah I implore you
I just watched Terminator 2 recently did
you like it yes turning there to holds
up yeah for me yes I loved it I loved it
too also at for Edward furlongs first
movie yeah great he's so good
yeah what are what are some movies that
people continually like I just looked
him up the other day
he looks terrible he's okay no he looks
like I think we all probably look
terrible like if I was in a movie when I
was 12 right now you'd be like oh you'd
be holding my hands if I was if I wasn't
he looks great looks great yes I think
like he looks like an older Harry Styles
no he looks like a young Jabba here's
what I think that's a young job of that
I think I very very [ __ ] still very
I think he's a great looking here's
right he's got a little Tim Curry
doesn't he oh there's a little Tim Curry
there but here's the thing he's got a
Palpatine's eyes too who knows the
context of this photo Palpatine's eyes
you got yourself an adult Edward pearl
you know you but you
if he's like he's like you know I do
need a haircut because if when I need a
haircut
you see if you see me one day and then
the next day I've gotten a haircut you
would honestly be like did you lose 10
pounds from last night and I'd be like I
know I look completely different
yeah even like just trimming my beard
and maybe that's why am i defending
Edward you know what you're right I want
I like the t1000 want to protect him
good you know who I want to protect the
t1000 towards the team and doesn't the
other one I never seen it I always
protect devon Sawa okay who the [ __ ]
that Casper
yeah the friend that goes yeah I will
protect him til the day I die but also
little giants will wait yeah Casper he
played Casper the ghost Casper yeah but
was he the voiceover is Casper he plays
both he was once a real boy now he's
Casper and then he goes back oh I never
saw that movie was it good but just the
way you defended Edward Furlong I'll do
that for you felt a responsibility yeah
impacted me as a child little giants
good call
yeah I spot is he alive remember that
yes oh yeah babies as [ __ ] alive of
course he is what's his [ __ ] doing now i
acting probably just like Edward
furlongs wit but where is he I think
he's okay
family man now yeah what else do you
want to know about him looks good oh he
seems very young yeah yeah yeah he's got
kind of a you know when the lips are
like that though I don't like it what
kind of lips I want to see yeah what is
it about the lips what is it very
untrusting I don't trust the lips the
lips I their this they look like there's
no lips
there's lips there absolutely let me ask
you this is it the lips or is it the
nose you think it's the list that logic
checks out that is that is a very
logical and I
I mean just to be clear I'm not saying
that's a bad nose high for certain I
have no ground to stand on when it comes
to me but I think I think I know what
you mean like you see those eyes and
that nose and there's something about it
you're like don't you smirk at me
yeah but also in the back your head
you're like I bet that dude could kick
my ass
me for sure yeah for sure you know I was
gonna say the way I met Margaret Cho
back to when do we met David Cross the
one yeah is is that I was at Dublin's I
say this already know